my father wanted his statute or more
from beast to man to remind us that
anything is possible
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
King Ben might be a nice person but he's
got beast DNA running through his veins
everyone has a dark side but Ben's is a
little more beastly than the average
person's we know for a fact that Ben
will transform into a beast in
descendants 3 but we don't exactly know
why watch until the end to find out why
Ben is taking a page from his father's
fairy tale book and why he and now have
a lot more in common than you think Ben
is the son of Belle and the Beast from
the legendary Disney fairy tale Beauty
and the Beast he was born in auradon a
United Kingdom created by his father and
Cinderella's fairy godmother but beast
wasn't always the King of Aragon much
before that he was a French Prince hey
we said French friends not Fresh Prince
aha that's better
anyway he was a prince who was so
incredibly selfish and cruel that he was
cursed by an enchantress and turned into
a beast and yeah you know the rest of
the story
although Belle's love eventually broke
the curse and the couple went on to have
a healthy human child his son King Ben
somehow turns into a beast in
descendants three in the trailers we see
Ben in his best form lunging at Harry
hook and Gil but now in auradon did then
go from clean-shaven
to a full face of fur in a matter of
seconds well unfortunately for Ben there
are many reasons why the apple doesn't
fall far from the tree since Adam became
a beast after being cursed it's possible
that the same thing happens to Ben it's
obvious from the trailers that Audrey's
going on a crime spree we're pretty sure
she stills the Queen's crown and
Maleficent scepter after Ben proposes to
mal although Audrey had ulterior motives
for dating Ben they never really
apologized for dumping her for mal sure
he was under a love spell but he did
publicly humiliate her during a tour
nemat
yeah all in all Ben should have
apologized to Audrey and kept a low
profile as she digested the news instead
he paraded mal through the Aragon
corridors
if there's anyone who has a bone to pick
with them it's definitely Audrey and if
she does indeed have Maleficent scepter
then she's totally going to turn Ben
into the Beast she thinks he is another
possible theory is that Ben's condition
is genetic and that every boy and his
family will battle with the beasts curse
so if they ever find themselves acting
selfishly they'll turn into a beast and
need true love's kiss to set them free
Ben's a nice guy sure he's done some
things he shouldn't have but Audrey's
totally exaggerating his father spent a
long time in a beasts body
so perhaps his DNA was altered somewhere
down the line but surely there are other
ways his beasts self could take over
there's also the possibility that then
has turned into a beast before but that
he's never told mal about it we just
hope that mal will be as excited to see
Ben as a beast has been was to see mal
as a dragon
if the beasts curse runs through the
male side of the family tree we hope
that Ben and now have daughters instead
of sons
but if Ben's DNA and ex-girlfriend
somehow aren't behind Ben's beastly
transformation there are a few other
possible explanations
both Celia and Hades could have cursed
the king of auradon you shouldn't have
come and turning him into a beast like
his father before him just sounds like
poetic justice in the meet Celia trailer
we see Celia using her tarot cards on
been in the back of mouths limousine
could Celia have tricked Ben into
becoming a beast like her father tricked
prince naveen into turning into a frog
that's very possible Celia is very much
her father's daughter so she probably
wouldn't miss a chance to curse the king
of auradon in the official descendants 3
trailer we see Celia destroy Hades ember
and weaken seeking venom background as
she does this he looks like he's in the
middle of transforming into a beast and
before long we see him attacking Harry
and Gil so he was right next to Ben when
he turned into his father's worst
nightmare so it's possible that she's
behind the curse Hades is also a suspect
especially since we see him blasting
been in the official trailer then Carlos
and Jay are thrown backward when Hades
uses his ember against them since Hades
ember is the only thing strong enough to
break dragon's eye curse we're surprised
I've been in the BK survive the glass so
that kind of sinking maybe hey he wasn't
trying to hurt them maybe he was cursing
them this might be the reason why Ben
soon turns into a beast as for Carlos
and Jay we'll have to wait and see if
anything strange happens to them maybe
Carlos will turn into a dog like Jade
becomes a genie but from the looks of it
then Carlos and Jay will end up turning
into stone alongside Evie and dude the
dog
Uma could also be a person of interest
our revenge after all she does end up
owning Hades ember at some point in the
movie turning your enemy's boyfriend
into a beast sounds like a pretty fun
thing to do if you're an evil pirate but
come to think of it uma and Vince seem
to get along pretty well in descendants
- if you don't count her kidnapping him
that is and uma did seem surprised when
Celia destroyed Hades Ember so she might
not be the culprits were searching for
in the end Ben's own anger could be to
blame for his transformation mal tends
to transform into a dragon when she's
super angry or in danger so what if she
and Ben are a lot more alike than meets
the eye what if Ben gets so angry with
Celia for destroying Hades ember that he
turns into a beast and starts attacking
his enemies all of these theories could
totally check out but we've got our eye
on the princess in pink audrey has the
most motive and seems to be the one
behind the sleep spell so we wouldn't be
surprised if she turns Ben into a beast
as payback why do you think Ben is going
full beast mode and descendants three
let us know in the comment section give
this video a big thumbs up if you love
Disney's descendants and be sure to
subscribe to the things so you never
miss a video
thanks for watching see you later
[Music]